too much of modernity imagines that any
rule from the past is archaic and
outdated and fact is
some of them are and some of them are
outdated
but what they provided was necessary so
we need to figure out some new rules we
can't just say well then no rules is the
best way to go
you know we talk in the book about a
model for how it is that human beings
move from one niche to another
when one discovers that the wisdom of
the ancients doesn't apply to the
current environment there's a natural
process in which we bootstrap new ways
of being and so although this
predicament is unlike any transition
humans made before the toolkit for
dealing with such transitions is already
present
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
with brett and heather episode 114
brett and heather have a new book out
a hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
evolution and the challenges of modern
life
it gives information on how we can adapt
to an incredibly quickly changing
society and how we're not really built
for this kind of life and much more it's
kind of the culmination of their life's
work it's awesome it's just been
released on the 14th and is available
linked below
i love the work they do and think
they're amazingly brilliant they have a
very analytical way of thinking and
they're one of the saner couple of
voices that are out online right now we
spoke about evolution and biology and
men and women touched on the trans
debate going on right now monogamy
versus polygamy it was a really fun
conversation i hope you enjoyed this
episode and if you do please be sure to
hit subscribe
[Music]
brett and heather welcome to my podcast
thank you for having us mikayla yes
thanks
thank you guys so much for coming on i'm
so excited for this conversation it's
very nice to see you guys over zoom but
it feels like closer than my normal
distance on social media so nice to meet
you guys finally it's good to meet you
as well it does yeah it feels like we've
already met even though we obviously
have not and hopefully it'll happen in
person at some point
yeah hopefully i'm planning on moving to
the states so
maybe then really very nice yeah
nashville awesome
i'm excited i'm wearing my cowboy boots
anyway
before we get started uh for anyone who
if any person in my audience doesn't
know who you guys are can you guys give
a brief introduction about who you are
and what it is you do
take it away brett
uh heather and i are evolutionary
biologists who until 2017 were
professors at the evergreen state
college as the college melted down we
were
dragged into the spotlight as we were
chased off of campus by a deranged mob
that had mistaken us for racists
we now function in the virtual world we
are hosts of the dark horse podcast
which we do live streams on
uh
every saturday um sometimes not saturday
but generally saturday we have been
visiting fellows at princeton for the
last two years and we are
the co-authors of the book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century let me just add one
one additional dimension which is that
as evolutionary biologists we worked in
the tropics and so brett did a lot of
his destination work in panama and i did
mine in madagascar
and i ran study abroad trips in panama
and ecuador and the final one bret and i
did together with you know 20
30 students and our then um young
younger children
for 11 weeks through many many
ecosystems in ecuador from galapagos to
andes to amazon so that's you know the
kind of evolutionary biology we have
done ranges from trying to understand
you know the migration patterns of
butterflies to you know the taking back
to activities of bats the sexual lives
of poison frogs and of course how humans
have evolved throughout time and space
you guys are so cool
okay so i brought you on to talk about
your new book a hunter gathers guide to
the 21st century
and that will be out by the time this
podcast is out
when is it getting published we are
excited 14th september 14th that's right
that's so cool how long have you guys
been working on the book
gosh we've been talking about it for
over a decade haven't we um
it is born of the ideas that uh we were
generating back in grad school really in
the 90s when when brett was working in
panama and i was working in madagascar
and
the sort of the applied nature you know
there's a heavy theoretical
aspect to the book especially in the
beginning we introduce readers to
establish evolutionary theory and also
to a number of new things that we are
bringing to the field that we feel are
necessary updates to understanding how
evolution works and specifically how
humans have evolved
and then we go through just all of these
aspects of human behavior chapter by
chapter you know health medicine food
sleep sex gender on and on and on
and provide some
applied
wisdom we hope um to help modern people
live a life that both respects what our
history was and
how we can move forward and that's
that developed
really in part from
conversations in the classroom
in the labs in the field
around campfires with students over
those 15 years or so that we were
professors and
we were professors
at a place evergreen and in a way that
we came to know our students really
really well and so we came to understand
how
how they were understanding the broken
world that they were inheriting and that
in part you know our generation and the
generations before us had helped make
and you know how can how can we all
together help create a better future
than the one that many people seem to
think is the only one that is possible
i should probably add since many in your
audience will have had some familiarity
with what happened to us at evergreen at
the very end of our
teaching careers there that none of the
students in that deranged mob were ours
that our students were
quite loyal to us and in fact the
genesis of this book involves many of
them
insisting to the extent that they could
insist that we
bring the model that we were using to
teach them to a wider audience they many
of them experienced it as
transformative of the way they viewed
themselves and their own lives and they
wanted to be able to pass it on to
others who weren't going to end up
taking our classes maybe people at other
other schools and so
at the point that we found ourselves in
a position that we could write
essentially any book that we wanted it
made sense to write this book that we
have been asked for many times
okay so i think maybe we should start
with
humanity's reaction to covid
i assume that you get into that
in the book
so
is the is the reaction and how split
everybody is right now is that explained
by evolution
well let's just say it's not in the book
because we actually finished the first
draft we uh finished it in the amazon
heather and i went to a very remote
field station called tippatini which is
in the most diverse habitat on earth we
went there to finish up what we had been
doing and that was january 2020. it was
january 2020. as we emerged from the
amazon literally as our phones woke up
for the first time in a couple of weeks
we heard of novel coronavirus for the
first time and wondered whether this was
going to be you know yet another close
call like the original sars and mers or
whether it might be something
more but the book was finished before
covid happened
that said the toolkit in the book does
allow
one to
work independently and to analyze what
one is hearing about
the progression of the pandemic and our
response to it and and
we have found ourselves uh very
uncomfortably
in some controversy as a result of the
fact that a proper grounding in
evolution does suggest that our response
to this pandemic is uh largely
incoherent
um so
that's probably not where we should
spend our time today okay okay
well okay and
going sorry heather you go ahead no you
go ahead well one of the interesting
things about the timing was that as
brett said we we submitted the first
draft and of course we had some more
drafts and so we did add a few little
things here and there we do have an
afterward that just very very briefly
addresses sort of what the what the
global response to covet has has looked
like um but
our what we then did almost as soon as
we submitted the first draft of the book
was we started this podcast of ours
darkhorse that brett already mentioned
and
that was started in part as a response
to what we were seeing is very confusing
public messaging public health messaging
around covet and so you know from the
very beginning for instance we were
saying
um
wow the
the evidence suggests for instance that
this is not a virus that transmits
outside this is not a disease that you
end up getting if you're outside and
furthermore if you do get it if you
spend time outside you're probably going
to be better off and so
um really it's the the logic that we are
trying to introduce people to in the
book the evolutionary logic of how is it
you know what are humans at an
evolutionary level and how can we
underst understand ourselves from our
historical perspective and also from the
perspective of how we have to move
forward
so as to best make decisions and not
just make decisions but interpret
the pronouncements that are handed down
from on high you know do those
pronouncements make sense or don't they
so rather than
follow the scientists
you know
follow a scientific interpretation of
the world and try to make sense of it
for yourself
that said
one of the central themes of the book is
something we call hyper novelty which is
a state of change that is so rapid that
it outstrips our capacity to evolve in
response which is a remarkable thing
because human beings are by far the
fastest evolving creatures that exist
because so much of what we do is
actually in the software layer rather
than in the hardware layer it can change
extremely rapidly but the pace of change
is just simply too high and all through
the pandemic you can see
um that
this is occurring i mean even just the
simple fact of the rate at which this
disease spread around the globe is the
result of new technologies that
epidemiology
is um now taking advantage of like air
travel for example
okay so let's talk about this hyper
novelty thing for for for a sec so one
of the experiences i think my family's
had and you guys have definitely had um
is that
i guess i've been put in a position my
dad's certainly been put in a position
where things are happening so quickly
that like you said you can't adapt and
so everything seems a bit fake and i
would say most of society at the moment
is probably in a similar situation with
the pandemic where it's like is this is
this real so do you guys have ways to
combat that because i assume things are
just going to get weirder and faster and
weirder and faster with technology so
are there things we can do to get out of
this to like calm i guess our nervous
systems down and adapt properly
yeah i mean it depends on the domain but
but yes is the short answer and
one of the things to do is to recognize
that it is
the rate of change itself that is
speeding up and to do what you can
um you know first at the individual
level to to slow your own experiences
down and that and to make them more real
more embodied and that of course is more
difficult in a pandemic era where so
many of us are connecting over zoom over
over social media
um but also to recognize and you know
this is this may seem like it's
unrelated but but i think it's related
and it's definitely a theme throughout
the book
that um
humans
as many of us as think we are innumerate
and you know many people are sort of
proudly describe themselves as i don't
do math i don't understand numbers
it is still a tendency to once they hear
a number once they hear that this thing
is better than that or that this gives
you a hundred percent chance of
something right that it's those numbers
that you stick with and there's a
reductionism that this obscures that is
is really an error and you know people
imagine that if it's if it's a number
it's scientific and so we go after this
what you know what we think of as a
pseudo-scientific approach to an
understanding of the world that you can
use scientific tools where you're trying
to recognize patterns
and you know as much as you can about
what it is that you are as a human being
and you recognize patterns and you move
forward with with care and rigor and
compassion for other human beings but
you don't assume that just because
something has been measured that that's
the thing that should have been measured
or that it is being conveyed to you
properly
uh so that's that's part of it
it's also i mean it's consistent with
not being overly focused on the
quantification but
the fact is you're looking at patterns
and they function especially in the
realm of biology
in a logical way and so
one could in the early days of the
pandemic for example make a lot of
headway by simply reviewing the evidence
that was emerging and so
we looked at the evidence that said that
a huge number of cases in asia had been
looked at and with one exception none
could be traced to an outdoor
environment and we thought well that
rather changes everything doesn't it it
makes it appear potentially like
although we are being told that
everything is dangerous that in fact
most of the world above 99 that's
outdoors might well be safe well what
does that mean
it could mean a number of things it
could mean that uv light from the sun is
killing the virus in which case you need
to be careful at night and not during
the day well it turned out uv light does
kill the virus but the virus still
didn't transmit outdoors at night and so
the model developed and what we said
back then was take advantage of this
this is a great loophole that the the
pandemic has in it that we can make use
of that we can live normally outdoors
but
we have to be very careful because
viruses that come from wild creatures
and one way or another this one
ultimately has to have come from bats
those viruses have to transmit outdoors
and so if this virus has forgotten how
to do that it will learn it again if we
give it that opportunity so we we
cautioned people
make use of the outdoors take advantage
of it restore your psychology by
behaving more normally outside but be
cautious don't give it the chance to
move or it will learn this trick and we
will lose that advantage and all of that
was just simply a matter of looking at
evidence figuring out what the patterns
were and extrapolating carefully from
them
okay well that makes sense to me that's
certainly not what we did but it makes
sense this episode is brought to you by
understandmyself.com that's the
personality test i'm going off about all
the time it's developed by my dad over
the last 30 years with help from two
other phds at mcgill and harvard you get
a specialized personalized report after
completing the understand myself.com
assessment
it will help you understand your
personality in seriously uncomfortable
detail
understandmyself.com also allows you to
create a relationship report with your
romantic partner i wanted to stick this
ad in here because mom and dad are doing
it and we're going to do an interview
about it and i'm super excited stay
tuned for that in the next month or so
once you and your partner have completed
your own assessments you can connect
them to create a report providing a
description of what you might expect
from being a relationship together
be careful there
go to
understandmyself.com
to get a better understanding of how you
function and interact with people
understandmyself.com code mp for 10 off
enjoy the rest of the episode
not to sidetrack the conversation or
anything but um one part of your book
you spoke about how religion is adaptive
or it's some sort of
focus that perhaps humans need
as a species
can you guys get into that a little bit
i've been on a
bible reading kick which is like the
first time in my life that i've read the
bible and thought about it properly and
it's been improving my life
so i saw that part of your book and i
was like okay let's get into this a
little bit
yeah well let's put it this way we in
our evolutionary toolkit we
teach people how to figure out whether
or not things that they
are interested in are a product of
adaptive evolution and religion clearly
passes the test with flying colors it is
extremely expensive that is to say the
investment that religious people put
into their beliefs the number of things
that they are forbidden to do as a
result of those beliefs that's very
costly
it is complex and it is evolutionarily
long-standing in fact all successful
cultures have had
mystical belief systems so there's no
way it's not
consistent with evolution and really no
way it could be have been produced by a
different process but then the question
is
why especially in light of the fact that
religious traditions don't agree with
each other about cosmology they can't
all be correct
why is it that belief systems that
appear to be in conflict with each other
and with a scientific world view have
been so successful and
ultimately the answer is
belief systems are not designed to be
true they are designed to be useful
right if a belief system causes you to
behave in a way that is consistent with
your evolutionary interests it is likely
to spread whether or not it is a factual
description of the universe
now the funny thing is once you realize
that
then you also begin to realize that even
our scientific view is somewhat
perfectly literal but a lot of things we
describe in science they're actually
models at different levels of crudeness
and over time the crudeness goes down
and the literalness goes up but even a
scientific worldview has a certain
amount of this metaphorical belief in it
and you know we shoot for a scientific
worldview in which that is minimized but
it it's not zero in any field yet and in
some fields like biology where we're
still quite new uh in the process of
discovery there's an awful lot of
metaphor that does not line up perfectly
with what's going on inside of cells or
creatures and so the phrase that we use
in the book
and have used elsewhere um is that many
things that are conveyed in the world
including in many religions are
literally false but metaphorically true
and that metaphorical truth has in it
the the value that explains why people
use it going forward and so while uh
while a cover story that a person of a
particular faith or mythology gives you
may not actually square with the
underlying physical reality of the
universe that does not mean that that
story isn't incredibly valuable and so
one of one of the stories that we
provide in the book is of farmers in the
guatemalan highlands
who uh say that uh planting their crops
on the full moon is it planting or
harvesting actually um it is planting
it's planting the crops on the full moon
allows those farmers to uh basically be
in good with their gods that they are
that that is that is the way to
guarantee crop success because that is
what the gods want
and it's really very hard to imagine
that
that the moon
is
having any effect on crop success at all
and yet this belief persists and when a
couple of researchers went and looked it
turned out that indeed uh those farmers
that acknowledged and abided by this
ancient belief
that the gods smile on you when you
plant on the full moon had better crop
success they had to ask why like what
what could the moon possibly have to do
with this and the you know the modern
scientific interpretation of what the of
the explanation is
that if you coordinate if you
synchronize the timing of your crops
such that you are also all harvesting
such it's all coming into ripeness and
harvest time at the same time you
effectively satiate your predators the
crop predators all of the things that
would eat the crops
um are have all the crops available to
them at the same moment and so instead
of having a succession of crops to eat
everything that would be eating the
crops has it all at once and so everyone
gets some of their crops eaten but no
one gets all of their crops eaten and so
whereas if you were to plant when it was
convenient for you the first person
whose crops reached edibleness would
have their crop eaten and the population
of the pests would grow and so only by
planting them all at the same time does
the population of pests not have a
chance to grow and therefore it's the
smallest
amount of consumption across the entire
landscape right so you know do the
guatemalan farmers in the highlands of
guatemala have the terminology of
predator association and and and such no
they do not but um have they effectively
recognized that the moon is a giant sky
clock right and that by by following the
giant sky clock and synchronizing on the
basis of that that they have better
success that's fabulous and that does
you know that does not suggest that they
are
um
you know that they are somehow stuck in
a time past that has no relevance for
now it absolutely has relevance and the
fact that the story that goes along with
the behavior that is adaptive isn't
literally true actually doesn't matter
that is so cool
that's so cool
yeah i feel like
i feel like god is a simpler explanation
than the predator
stacy say
wow
yes
satiation sheesh i have a hard time with
that anyway that yeah that's very
interesting okay another section of your
book you talk about birth control and
women
for better or for worse
and worse yes both better and worse sure
okay okay what's the worst
well the worst is that it used to be
human social relations were rigged
around certain realities of reproduction
women because it is very expensive to be
stuck raising a child alone were
extremely careful not to engage sexually
with men who did not
demonstrate a willingness to commit to
them
and
the problem is that that's not a very
fair system right to have women have to
be on guard in order not to be stuck
raising children alone
is um an asymmetrical burden
on the other hand it does create a kind
of coherence and it had consequences
that were positive for men also if men
in order to
uh to be worthy of women enough to have
a sexual relationship with them had to
demonstrate capacity in the world that
would make them worth choosing and then
demonstrate a willingness to commit that
actually created
higher quality male behavior and so many
of the things about the world that
functioned were born of this sexual
asymmetry so we have we have lost
something
uh with the advent of birth control that
was actually functioning and we argue
very strongly in the book that what we
have gained is far greater um that we
have actually achieved
an a set of opportunities for women
um to expand our role in the world
beyond um beyond child care and sort of
you know homework uh that we were more
limited to before we had the capacity to
so control our our reproductive lives
but pretending that it comes with no
cost
is is a tragedy and we need to figure
out a way
to potentially get back some of the
value that we had before we had the
control while not giving up the control
that we now have you know the the
benefits to bridge role are are widely
understood
and um and you know frankly it benefits
men too because you know in those
spheres in you know basically in every
sphere where there are at least some
women who are interested in doing the
work um having women be capable of doing
the work and not having to you know
worry that they may at any moment be
sidelined by um by a family that they
didn't necessarily want
is of course good for everyone because
it brings everyone who wants to
contribute in any individual creative or
analytical sphere into that sphere but
but what has been lost is something it's
and it's not you know it's not
anti-feminist to say so it's just
recognizing that what evolution handed
us in this case um happens to have a
function to it and and it's disappeared
so how can we how can we recreate the
coherence of the relationships between
the sexes without asking for a
regressive backwards view of the world
and this is a theme across the book um
this is maybe one of the easier examples
to understand but in general we're stuck
in a predicament as essentially
modern hunter-gatherers in a
non-hunter-gatherer environment we are
stuck with the inability to go backwards
there's nowhere to go we can't return to
the 50s we can't return to hunting and
gathering
and we must go forwards but to go
forwards involves figuring out what
portion of that which made sense in the
past can be retooled
can be preserved and what needs to be
added to it to make it coherent in the
present and in every case we need to
essentially renegotiate our relationship
with each other and with our environment
so that it stops making us unhealthy
maybe one of the ways to
fix that predicament between men and
women
maybe maybe the lack of religion at the
moment is also contributing to that
because at least that gives you some
guidelines on how to behave that we
don't have so perhaps keeping some of
the scientific advancements we've made
and then looking at the world in that
kind of framework might be beneficial
yeah i mean i think it's it's very
analogous that you know we we aren't
religious people but um not having a
framework um that was coherent and that
at least aspects of which remain
coherent today
to for instance hand down to our
children makes things much more
difficult that you know we don't we
can't assume that we should share with
any of our pipers or any of our
children's friends and their families a
particular way of viewing the world or
of you know coming together for shabbat
or for church or for whatever right and
and with that of course we've also lost
the community that uh that a religious
uh faith will tend to give to you you
know so where do people meet now they
often meet online or they meet at work
and of course that's just too difficult
now like you know how is it that you're
gonna negotiate a potential romance at
work so where where do you be you meet
online or at bars or in other social
situations that are ever more fraught
and without shared rules and i think too
much of modernity imagines that any rule
from the past is archaic and outdated
and fact is
some of them are and some of them are
outdated
but what they provided was necessary so
we need to figure out some new rules we
can't just say well then no rules is the
best way to go we need we need some
framing that's said
you know we talk in the book about a
model for how it is that human beings
move from one niche to another
when one discovers that the wisdom of
the ancients doesn't apply to the
current environment there's a natural
process in which we bootstrap new ways
of being and so although this
predicament is unlike any transition
humans made before the toolkit for
dealing with such transitions is already
present and in fact we're doing it right
here we're talking about what the
predicament is what it says you know
we're recognizing that the
the modern pseudo-sophistication that
basically decides
any sort of self-regulation in the
context of
uh mating and dating is you know
oppressive or stodgy well that's
nonsense and so
what we are expecting to see
is
that as people increasingly recognize
that a free-for-all in the the area of
sex and romance is not causing anybody
to be satisfied or happy quite the
opposite that people will start opting
out and that means that they will opting
out of the free for them yeah they're
opting out of the free-for-all and that
what they will do is they will figure
out crudely at first what rules they
want to abide by and interact with
others who see the same picture
and over time they will figure out how
to improve those rules so that they're
more effective at replacing
uh the values that were in the systems
that were lost while not losing the
gains that we've made through
interventions like birth control
that sounds tough for people
like how to figure out play a game
together figure out new rules for
everything
take some from from old rules and
make up new ones that seems like it's
going to take a while
well
as long as things start getting better
quickly doesn't really matter that it
takes a while that's how human beings uh
change their their position matters to
me
well right but you already probably have
a pretty good idea
what some of the things that don't make
sense are and just simply recognizing
others who see that same picture and you
know
limiting your interaction
to people of similar world view is an
obvious thing to do
so i think we've just we've done it very
crudely because many of the
you know technological enhancements
seem like they just simply provide more
of what's good and it takes a while to
discover what the hidden costs are and
there and i mean i think part of the
message that you've already alluded to
michaela is
that we're going too fast you know the
rate of change is itself part of the
problem and so slowing down will
inherently um hopefully you know change
slow the rate at which we are
progressing in poor directions but it
also means that we aren't going to get
quick fixes
we will hopefully slow the rate of decay
and
find new better ways to move forward you
know not not moving backwards not moving
forward so quickly with so many
uninvestigated changes
that can't be undone but moving towards
something in in all of these realms with
regard to religion with regard to sex
and gender
with regard to you know with regard to
food and school and you know just so
many things
moving towards
a well an adaptive foothill in the
language of evolutionary biology and you
know we don't claim in the book to
provide a blueprint because you know any
anyone who does anyone who says i got
this i know exactly what it's going to
look like
they can't so they're they're either
fooling themselves or they're trying to
fool you
and
we do think that we can find our ways to
to many hopefully of these adaptive
foothills across many of these domains
and from then
collectively all all of us humans
working together find our way up the
adaptive slope to some place better than
we are now because it really feels like
across so many domains we're in an
adaptive valley and it just feels dark
and
and people are filled with despair for
good reason
so when you guys talk about slowing down
what does that look
like well in in what context
okay say
you mentioned
diet you mentioned gender
i would assume politics like what do you
mean just not making any
life-changing and country changing
decisions too quickly like what does
slow down look like well one of one of
the things would be with regard to diet
say um
we talk in the book about some of the
great
successes of western medicine
antibiotics and vaccines and surgery are
just three of the amazing successes of
western medicine
and that doesn't mean that at every
moment you should apply those
those solutions to any given problem
right there are problems which those are
not the solutions we now know
that the over prescription of
antibiotics to livestock has made our
livestock sick and our ecosystem sick
and our people sick
and so slow down
on taking a success and saying i'm now
going to globalize that i'm going to
take this thing which is
is a grand success and generalize and
globalize so quickly that it may be
impossible to undo
so there are two tools that are really
the mirror image of each other that we
describe in the book one is the
precautionary principle where when
something is new you assume that it has
hazards until it's demonstrated to be
safe and the other is chesterton's fence
named after gk chesterton who first
outlined uh the logic of it and in his
formulation
if two people happen onto a fence that
appears to have no value and one of them
proposes that maybe it should just be
eliminated the other person's response
should be not until you figured out what
the value of it was once you know that
what the value of it was you're in a
position to say whether it still has
that value but until you know what the
value of it was you have no idea you may
be removing something very functional
and in fact there are many examples in
medicine and elsewhere where things that
were very important were not understood
to be so
by a an establishment that simply hadn't
spotted their value yet so
moving slower means applying both of
these things when you come up with
something
new i mean you know we
all remember the
the invention of the first smartphone
right the first
smartphone seemed
a very interesting new way to do things
but it obviously carried huge hazards
with it and it took over the world
before anybody had a chance to to notice
what the hazards
were right and it may be that it is in
fact playing a huge role
in our increasingly dysfunctional
social
uh environment and the
breakdown of institutions and governance
that has followed along with it so
even something like the smartphone that
seems like it's just going to be an
enhancement to life is something one
should treat with great caution at the
point it's introduced
yeah i find it difficult to believe that
going forward things aren't going to get
harder aren't going to get harder like
technology is going to take on i i
assume an entirely different even
dimension
um and
i don't understand how we can adapt to
that without i think going backwards a
little bit and not getting rid of the
scientific achievements we've had but
simplifying lives like perhaps this has
only recently occurred to me but perhaps
living in a high-rise condo in the
middle of a city surrounded by stressful
people makes you more stressed because
you haven't adapted to be surrounded by
stressful people without also being
stressed
and so you talk about getting into
nature and how important that is
um and i think that kind of
i think that's kind of like going
backwards a little bit
what do you guys think it's it's
certainly harkening back to an earlier
time um and
yes but when when we say you can't go
backwards
we are really alluding to sort of a
traditionalist you know usually a
conservative view of like wasn't it all
great then like wasn't there a moment in
you know the medium past um to which we
can aspire and we would say you know no
no but
have there been missteps in modern times
that we absolutely should try to undo
for sure and in fact the the sooner we
do that the better and you know the idea
that
living in high rises popular you know
densely populated with a whole bunch of
other stressed people may actually cause
you to be stressed as well
at one level of course at another level
certainly science doesn't have the
answers all of the answers to why that
should be the case yet
but just because we don't again with the
productionism right like just because we
can't pinpoint exactly all of the
reasons why an evolutionary framework an
evolutionary lens allows you to say you
know what
this way of living is so new is so new
that we couldn't possibly be fully
adapted to it yet let's identify as many
of the ways as possible that this is
very counter to anything we've done
before let's try to understand all of
the ways that's likely to be harming us
but just because we may not have all of
them does not mean that we should just
forge ahead until and unless we can i
until unless we can demonstrate that
this is actually safe again the
precautionary principle would suggest
just you know what you know or if you
know if for whatever reason you are
obliged to live that way um try you know
do your best to get out into some kind
of nature with some kind of regularity
it's amazing i mean this is again just
sort of you know mechanistic very small
level science but even just having a
tree visible outside your window
provides um enough access to nature that
people have lower levels of stress
hormones like it you know
it's not that's not enough but it's it's
also at the same time enough to make
things better so you know you don't need
to go back fully to nature you don't
need to spend the two weeks in the
amazon that we did while we were
finishing this book although we
recommend it to anyone who can manage
that it's extraordinary
but really just having anything that
isn't of the social that isn't of the
human made around you and being free of
the
of the thoughts and the voices and the
sounds and the smells of the of other
people for some period of time as
regularly as you can will help you
recenter yourself and remember what it
is that you actually care about like you
know what is it that you as an
individual
could be doing that could make the world
a better place for you and the ones you
love and everyone it's harder to do that
when you're constantly getting input
from all the other people
so we talk in the book about
us having
cautiously begun to retool traditions
that we inherit from religion
and so our hanukkah tradition in the
house involves a different principle for
each night of hanukkah that we talk
about with the kids and as they get
older they understand it with
more and more sophistication and one of
the principles involves
what we call a need for reversibility
so in a situation where you are
condemned to confront technological
change and you can't possibly know what
the implications are going to be it
would be foolish to adopt anything that
you couldn't unadopt upon the discovery
that it was more harmful than it was
beneficial and so
how do you operationalize that it's a
difficult puzzle but whether we should
recognize that anytime we do something
we couldn't undo if we had to that we
are putting ourselves in danger even
just that simple recognition makes us
safer
interesting
okay
that makes sense you spoke earlier about
hanging around people who have the
proper world view but i would assume
that
um many of the people that i
disagree with
probably think that they have the proper
world view so there are tricks are there
tricks to figuring out
whether or not your world view is the
proper world view or is a healthy world
view
well you can't know if your worldview is
the proper world to you and probably
none of ours are the proper worldview
even those of us who work quite hard to
get it right are liable to be imprecise
uh
fairly often
but one trick that i've learned is
when you have a divide between you and
others figuring out where that divide
begins is
um often incredibly enlightening so for
example
um i'm a
a liberal and i believe that
environmentally we've made terrible
errors that we're degrading the planet
at a rapid rate and that we have an
obligation to do something about it and
i know that if i walk into a room of
conservatives
that we're going to differ in all
likelihood about
global climate change
but i also know
that i can ask an audience of
conservatives i can say
well if you believed that human beings
were altering the atmosphere in a way
that was going to substantially change
the temperature of the planet in a way
that was going to degrade its quality
for future generations
would you be interested
in engaging a solution that would slow
or halt that process
i always get agreement on that question
and so then i know that what we really
differ over is whether or not this is
happening or whether or not it is human
caused and what the solutions might be
but that's
half of the difference that might exist
between us erased in one question right
now we know that what we really need to
talk about is well what is the evidence
that's happening and what are the
solutions that might work
and that's a much easier discussion so
i guess the the upshot is figure out
what you actually disagree about before
you start disagreeing
yeah and i would add um you know people
you should engage with everyone at some
level right like people who you disagree
with especially
you are likely to learn more from them
if you can speak to each other with
civility but there are a couple of
things that i tend to look for and that
i think are valuable probably
universally no matter no matter
what other demographic things are true
of you you know religious atheist old
young white black female male doesn't
matter
you need to be
not just willing to but
adamant that you will error correct when
you discover errors
and have a curiosity about the world so
error correction and curiosity and those
two things get you a long long way and
you know that that's not an
encapsulation of the scientific method
that's not sufficient it's there's not
enough formalism there but those two
things get you a long way to that like
error correction and curiosity and
exposing yourselves to people who don't
agree with you will actually allow you
to modify your worldview such that it
probably hopefully will come into better
agreement with what is actually true
yeah so basically being okay with being
wrong
absolutely and and you know i think i
think this is farther down the list of
importance but
taking enough risks in your thinking and
i would say also physically and
psychologically but we're talking sort
of analytically creatively right now
taking enough risks in your thinking
that you are wrong sometimes like if
you're never wrong you're probably not
taking enough risks
and so that means though that you will
have to do the error correction and
coming back to people and saying man i
was wrong that sucks right it doesn't
feel good
so if you're going to be someone who is
pushing the boundaries of what you
yourself understand and what you know
that is basically going to guarantee
that you will have to sometimes say to
people i was wrong here's how i know
here's what i think now i may still be
wrong but i know i was wrong about that
and you have to be willing to do that
this is why you should never be 100
certain about anything i feel like in
the past whenever i got stuck into a
frame of mind where i was like oh no 100
this is it i always just got walloped it
hasn't it's happened a few times with
like autoimmunity and medical system and
like oh diet plays a role type of thing
where it was like everything i believed
was completely wrong i was like oh that
hurts and so now i just try and be
careful like if i ever feel too certain
about something i'm like uh maybe
there's something there to poke around
into
absolutely this is actually something
that brett has done with our boys in
particular with regard to
asking them how certain they are of a
conclusion
right and and
anytime they say a hundred percent and
say well
now i know what you're doing wrong right
you're being categorical and it's not
that it's not that there aren't things
that you could work your way to near
certainty about
but
if you didn't start out with you know if
you didn't start out with some doubt
then it's very unlikely you've figured
out what might be wrong with your
perspective and it's also a very useful
trick when you are talking to somebody
who
has a perspective that conflicts with
yours asking them
what they think the chances are that
they are substantially an error
will
force them to reveal that they haven't
checked into the question or it will
cause them to recognize that there
actually is some room for doubt and to
figure out where it exists and those are
keys forward
oh i really like that i'm so glad i
found some other people who do that
that's how my conversations with people
go i'm like no no i'm like 94 sure about
this no 87 okay like only 60 but
60. but i'm glad that i'm glad that
that's not just a me thing that's fine i
don't know
it can be baffling to people right but
um
but it's so useful it's so useful
yeah definitely
okay
i have some other more questions here
that i want to get to before i
um before i let you guys go
you talked about okay so i'm
talking about you know allergies
autoimmunity and all this stuff because
of what happened to me
and you guys talk a bit about how that's
a result of
too much change too quickly
potentially so can you get into that a
little bit about allergies autoimmunity
this
how north america is kind of ill at the
moment not just with kovid but with
actual you know obesity depression etc
yeah sure
first the thing to realize is if you
were to stand on a street corner and
just watch people walk by
you'll see a tremendous amount of
pathology and that isn't normal right if
you were to
hang out in a forest and watch creatures
go by you probably would see essentially
none and some of that is about the fact
that when pathology arises
a predator will often take advantage of
it but a lot of it has to do with the
fact that we are just doing so many
novel things that are causing pathology
and in many cases we don't have any idea
what they are and so
you know it is an amazing fact that if
you stand on that street corner you will
see
obese people walk by regularly we know
obesity is unhealthy that it degrades
life and we also know that whatever it
is that causes that is something that is
happening to them after they've been
at least conceived and probably born
which means that if we could figure out
what it was and stop doing it we could
cure that problem how much human
well-being would be increased if we
cured that problem so the fact that we
are not obsessed with figuring out the
root cause is odd yeah
but when we talk for instance about the
hygiene hypothesis uh which is not new
with us but the idea that we have again
with the antibiotics really you know
we've over cleaned our environments
we've made our environment so sterile
um by misunderstanding uh
that microorganisms basically and
imagining that everything
that is bacterial is bad and so this you
know this is a trend that started before
we came to understand the gut microbiome
and we still don't understand it as
you're well aware but we understand it a
lot more than we did 40 years ago
and so the idea that
we know it exists exactly start the idea
that we contain multitudes and that
wiping out those multitudes because
we're scared of some germs
is probably bad for us is you know
really base level like it really is not
a finesse understanding but it does
provide a framework for understanding
what a lot of autoimmune disorders
probably
are emerging from allergies and then
there's a similar kind of oh i've got
the solution therefore i'm going to
generalize it
for instance
[Music]
our approach to
uh you know
it's just the the molecules that we have
exaggerated sugar tastes good
right and so we are going to
concentrate it and put it in everything
to make us want more and you know that's
that's our modern environment taking
advantage of our ancient desires
add markets and we're off to the races
so
the immune system is a
developmentally sensitive
literally a complex system
it requires that in your early life it
has the correct
exposures to detect the difference
between the molecules that you yourself
make and the molecules that you don't
make and literally what it what it
determines is
very early in development it recognizes
those molecules that you make before
you're born before it's exposed to the
outside world and it eliminates the
fraction of immune cells that react to
those molecules so what's left over
are immune cells that only react to
molecules you don't make
now the problem is
that system is not supposed to encounter
for example things that you eat yes
things that you eat are not molecules
that you make and therefore if your
immune system is allowed to see them it
will regard them as hostile just as it
will regard pollen as hostile and it
will react to it and so
uh these food sensitivities are like an
autoimmune disorder to your food right
an autoimmune disorder in the narrower
sense is you reacting to your own
molecules as if they were the molecules
of a foreign invader all of these things
are going to be the result of exposures
that are novel that is to say if you had
developed in your ancestral environment
the inputs to the system would not have
caused you to react to your food or to
your own molecules in this way so the
question again as with the obesity
question is well
what is the root cause of the immune
system encountering molecules that it
shouldn't be seeing
or having the wrong reaction and how can
we stop
how can we stop doing that so those in
the future will not experience those
things and again we're not nearly
curious enough about the question we're
much more interested for example in
treating these things as chronic
conditions than figuring out why they
happened and not causing them anymore
i just read an article this morning so
i'm very into the autoimmune research
and anything that has to do with leaky
gut specifically so food sensitivities
and autoimmunity and i read an article
this morning it was like groundbreaking
news leaky gut contributes can
contribute to rheumatoid arthritis and
here's the drug to fix it and i i was
just like okay so like another 30 years
before they link leaky gut to diet
eh i don't know do you think things are
going to get better
well they have to
right i mean you have to we're on a
trajectory in which they can't they
can't get worse much longer and so in
some sense that's frightening but it's
also
the thing that is likely to cause people
to wake up and recognize that we have a
system for example
a system
where markets find
any opportunity where something can be
sold at a profit and exploit it
and some fraction of what's being sold
at a profit is actually harmful to us
and so
uh
we have to recognize that this system
being allowed to run its course is
damaging people and we have to reign it
in will we do it
very hard to say but
certainly the first step is recognizing
that that process is going to continue
to have us
cause
disease at all levels
and uh we should certainly be attempting
not to do that
yeah i hope so i feel like just looking
at
well maybe soviet union or other
situations that got pretty turbulent i
feel like things got more turbulent than
they are now before they switch
directions so it's a bit concerning
it is concerning yeah and this and you
know every moment that you're living
through is later than all the previous
instantiations and so you know we've got
more novelty more hyper novelty more
technological advancement now and so you
know
history will not repeat itself you know
to what degree it will rhyme we don't
yet know
okay okay i've got a few more questions
you guys talk about gender and monogamy
and how part of at least part of that is
adaptive so can we get into that a
little bit
we are
very much in favor of both gender and
monogamy they're both excellent um
yeah well let's let's separate these
issues when you say gender you're really
talking about uh
the phenomenon
of people
um switching genders or
ascribing
to different genders than yeah uh than
they were when they were
younger
so there's a very ancient history of
people
uh
functioning as what we would now call
trans that exists in many cultures
what is not ancient
is the ability to alter one's physiology
with
hormone interrupting drugs
or to alter their bodies with surgery
it is also the case
that the pattern in which people are
telling us that they
feel that they are a different gender
than the one
uh that we would um
that follows their sex that we would
yeah that follows their sex is the right
way to say it
is suggestive of a contagious process
and that that is likely not a natural
phenomenon it is likely a result of
things like
cell phones and social media causing
belief systems to be transmitted in a
novel way which suggests that those
are likely to be very unhealthy patterns
so let me take a slightly different tack
i think gender and monogamy are um
are distinct
pretty distinct in my mind because we
have what some will view as a
traditional
regard for monogamy but it doesn't come
from traditional uh logic it comes from
evolutionary logic
and we have a very untraditional or at
least i do and i think we must both i
have a very non-traditional view of the
value of almost all gender norms so you
know gender is the
behavioral expression of sex sex is
binary
sex is at least 500 million years old
and our lineage alone may be closer to
one and a half billion years old
it's not um it doesn't change in in
mammals you can't change your sex
gender being the behavioral
manifestation of sex and us being a
species that is actually much more
monogamous and there's lots of evidence
for this but much more monogamous than
really any of our close relatives
you would expect that the behavioral
manifestations of our sex
would be more flexible in us than they
are in many other species
that the reasons to have very different
female female behaviors and from from
male behaviors are not nearly as strong
in a species that is has you know
relatively low levels of sexual
dimorphism as we have
um but then it's also obviously true
that we do have sexual dimorphism that
we are different that women are
different from men and that women will
always be
[Music]
constrained by some aspects of anatomy
and physiology by gestation and
lactation right that's never going to be
the domain of men and pretending
otherwise is just reality denying so you
know are there things that are
downstream of being
of being female and therefore capable of
bringing a child into the world and and
suckling that child at your breast of
course there are
can men be paternal in a way that is
like
a maternal engagement with their own
offspring yes they can but that is newer
and so it's not going to be as
it's not going to be the default in the
way that maternal behavior with their
own with their own babies will be so i
would say
you know gender non-conformity is
fabulous if that's you know if that's
who you are and it was who i was um
that's terrific and gender
non-conformity is very different from
gender dysphoria gender non-conforming
is like hey you know i was a tomboy i
vastly preferred doing math and climbing
trees to playing with dolls and having
tea parties i just never did the never
did the dolls and tea parties thing i
did a lot of playing in the dirt and
with numbers
and i never once thought i was a boy i
was never once told by anyone if you
like matthew reboy in part guess what
that's progressive that's outdated
regressive sexism is what that is
so
it's also true that um i'm in a stable
long-term loving monogamous relationship
that's also heterosexual and we've got
two beautiful children and
okay i didn't happen to love pregnancy
at all but um i loved everything else
past pregnancy and it wasn't that it was
because i really thought i was a man or
anything like that right like
there are things that are just
prescribed and like it or not it's true
you know if you want to have
children that are genetically your own
and you're female you're gonna end up
bearing them you know there's some
modern technologies which allow people
to do that who really have no other way
around it but you know we we are
the result of three and a half billion
years of evolution
and for
almost half of that probably we've been
sexual beings still getting around it
how we behave in the modern world with
regard to our norms almost all of that
is flexible and almost all of that
flexibility is to the good
yeah i will say heather was terrible at
being pregnant but i would have been
worse yes i was gonna say
you try it though yeah no i just believe
me you you did beautifully from my
perspective uh
at least because you freed me from the
burden of attempting it but um
let's get to the the point about
monogamy though uh our point in the book
is that monogamy
is a complex story the fact that we have
sexual dimorphism it's not a radical
sexual dimorphism but there's a
difference in average size between males
and females and that says that there's a
long history of non-monogamy in
humans that said
the way the fact is sorry you have to
slow down there for a sec
what what's suggested of a long history
of non-monogamy when you look at species
that are monogamous if you look at
gibbons for example
you will find that males and females are
the same size right that they are armed
similarly and the reason is because if
the system
has sexual conflict if males are trying
to exclude each other from mates then
they end up being favored in species
like ours to be larger right because
size allows them to displace other males
larger and with a greater weaponry like
in terms of muscle mass or bigger teeth
you know just the ability to fight with
with the weapons they've got so females
are closer to the ecological optimum of
what the species should be and then
males are distorted by sexual
competition
um in
other species species that compete in
three dimensions males can end up being
smaller because agility in flight for
example may be the mode of competition
and sometimes the competition may be
about song or colorful plumage you know
it can look a lot of ways but the men
the men the males will tend to be in
polygenic species sure you're in some
way and as as brett says you know
farther off what would be the ecological
optimum for the species if there were no
sexual competition going on so we are a
sexually dimorphic species we are not
radically so but we are somewhat so
which says there's been a lot of
polygony but that's less so than our
closest relatives right less so than our
closest relatives which means that
recent evolution has reduced that
dimorphism we've been moving in the
direction of monogamy and
more to the point
the
recent history of our species is one in
which monogamous cultures have
flourished and spread and so most people
alive on earth today come from cultures
that are monogamous and so as much as
our ancient history may involve some
degree of polygony our modern
evolutionary history points in the
direction of monogamy and from our
perspective
we shouldn't really care what evolution
wants for us evolution is not an
honorable process but we can understand
that the advantages that caused monogamy
to uh spread in recent evolutionary
history are advantages that we should
value and therefore we should stabilize
monogamy in humans so those advantages
include a reduction in
violence
a reduction in
war-likeness so violence within your
population right and the tendency of a
population to attack other populations
will be increased by polygamy which
tends to sideline a certain number of
males right for every male who has
multiple
uh partners there will be at least one
male who has none
those sexually frustrated males who are
left out of mating and dating can very
easily be turned into an army to seek uh
profit abroad and
uh frankly the history of warfare is one
with a an awful lot of sexual violence
associated with it too so right so just
to be clear the the violence that is
reduced as you move from a politionist
to a monogamous society will be both men
against other men but also men against
women that both of those kinds of
violence will be reduced right and um
the
fact is human babies are incredibly
labor intensive to raise yes a
monogamous culture is one in which that
burden is distributed much more fairly
right because monogamous cultures bring
all males who are uh capable of
being brought into child rearing into
the
um into the system and therefore
distributes the labor more broadly it
creates
siblings that are
full siblings rather than half siblings
so their tendency to cooperate will go
up so the long and short of it is if you
like things like a safer world in which
war is rarer
if you like the idea that the labor of
raising the next generation should be
more broadly distributed that it
shouldn't fall so heavily on the
shoulders of women but should be shared
between men and women
if if you like any of these things then
really you want a monogamous system
because it causes these things to happen
and
the advantages are really so unambiguous
that this ought to be a primary concern
unfortunately the thing that seems to
have favored or at least the argument
that we make in the book the thing that
seems to have favored the spread of
monogamy
is the expansion of human populations
because an expanding population
does better if it can grow faster and
because monogamy brings all of the
adults who can in principle be involved
in child rearing into that activity it
means the number of offspring that can
be raised goes up
the flip side of this is that when you
reach the end of an opportunity when a
population has grown and expanded as far
as it can go monogamy will tend to break
down and males will again start
displacing each other from mating
opportunities which is exactly what
we're seeing not just in what we
think of as polyamory which is really a
euphemism
but in what we call serial monogamy
which is also a euphemism serial
monogamy is really a name for what we
should call serial polygony it is in
fact
individual males raising multiple
families
in sequence and that does have the
tendency to exclude other males from
animating opportunities at all which is
going to bring about exactly the harms
that we were discussing
wow
that's so interesting
so
so that's a decline in society as well
potentially but could that be is that
because our
why is that happening is that because
there are too many people and it's just
an evolutionary adaptation
or is that because everyone's glued to
their phones and going crazy
it's not really the phones it was
happening well before we had smartphones
um really what it is like 60s 70s
it was kind of happening then right it
yes and
i think what we were really feeling is
evolutionarily for game theoretic
reasons as you bump up against the
limits of population the outbreak of
male male competition and the tendency
to favor this kind of behavior
goes up now
civilizations counteract that right it's
very interesting that for example
um
christianity
has favored monogamy
right even though christianity obviously
is a system in which powerful males who
would be exactly those you would expect
to benefit from polygyny have made the
rules
right so really what this is is an
evolutionary paradox well where
evolution is the solution to a paradox
that we would otherwise see where
powerful males have made rules that seem
to favor
less powerful males and others
and the reason uh has to do with what we
were just discussing but it enhances
stability
right it enhances stability and
therefore these belief systems have been
carried along with the behaviors that
have enhanced the power of those who
held those belief systems and frankly
you know i think i think you're right um
that sort of the 60s 70s is when a lot
of these things began to decohere some
and this gets us back to the point about
things like birth control which is
amazing and necessary and
i don't know any women who would have us
go back
i don't know if i know any men who would
have us go back but i know that i don't
know any women who would have us go back
pre-you know widely and freely available
birth control
that said
once it became available it allowed
women
to um to behave
like not very interesting men sexually
as opposed to
encouraging men to behave like
good women right so we're like
we went lowest standard denominator on
sexual behavior instead and and used
used wide access to birth control which
again is a boon as an excuse
as opposed to going like this is amazing
let's now be a be able to plan our
families and not find ourselves trapped
and thus in lives that we never intended
for ourselves when it when there was a
mistake that was made um but rather
let's let's use this
and also be our best selves and not not
fall into
you know the the cad
strategy of men why you know why why
should women behave like men at their
worst yeah i want to refine one thing
about this men have two reproductive
strategies right one involves producing
offspring that one does not invest in
and the other involves producing
offspring that one invests heavily in
and when men are operating according to
that second strategy they are naturally
similar to women in their choosiness and
uh their
their behavior so really the question is
why in a system where technology has
allowed us to effectively choose what
kind of behavior we want to engage in
why would we default to that
initial male strategy and try and induce
women to behave that way rather than
urge both men and women to their better
high investment strategy which makes the
world function makes people happier
creates healthier children with
good role models we basically we
defaulted to the
worst or the second worst mode depending
upon how you view it
and we bypassed the obvious solution
which was to encourage
responsible behavior in the context of
mating and dating of a kind that has a
very long history with humans
well i mean people do that because
it's more fun in the short term and
we're not taught about long-term fun
um yeah on the other hand i'm not sure i
think it seems like it should be more
fun in the short term
but people are really dissatisfied and i
think that they need to notice they've
never been sexually freer
but
it's hard to imagine an era in which
there has been so much complaining about
the sexual environment those two things
are two sides of the same coin that
freedom wasn't so wonderful and the fact
is
the
we needed to be grateful for the freedom
that was provided by birth control and
we need to treat it carefully rather
than see it as you know license to get
rid of all of the rules and the
coherence of the system and then at the
point that we did that foolishly and it
produced
a huge amount of dissatisfaction and
frankly sexual violence and
all sorts of other things this is a
place where reversibility has to be the
key if it didn't work if it produced a
paradoxical outcome where instead of
being tremendously sexually satisfied
people are frustrated and angry about
their sex lives then maybe the answer is
well
where where was our wrong turn
yeah yeah so
we we imagine that simply maximizing
freedom is always the thing that will
make us most satisfied and it's not
inherently and that exists at the same
time as the recognition
that the ancient system put much more of
the burden on women
and that birth control has the capacity
to relieve some of the
unfairness if you will of the ancient
system
and and make it one in which men and
women can both be their best selves um
out in the world but that does not mean
that we should simply act as if um no
constraint is the best policy because
it's clearly not as as brett said you
know
we we taught undergraduates for 15 years
and we knew them very very well and
we heard from many of them
how unsatisfying this world was with
regard to um relationships and
expectations
yeah
i agree i think that goes for a number
of things too not just relationships and
and sex and maybe if you're hooking up
with a bunch of people
and you're miserable you could try
hooking up with fewer people that seems
it does seem a little counterintuitive i
can understand that but i think that has
to go with also
um you know screen time
diet too
just over doing it being like you get a
little bit of joy so you're like okay
that's the direction i should go in but
if you're overall if you're overall
unhappy with your life then maybe you
need to restrict some areas i think
that's smart yeah
i mean every everyone knows the term
junk food but we talk about junk food
junk sex junk entertainment yeah you
know the junk the junkification of the
choices that are available to us which
exactly as you say prioritize the short
term over the long term
and those of us who have changed our
diets right for instance um or who have
always been on a diet that that
encourages the eating of real whole food
know that that's delicious but if you
currently eat junk food you might
imagine that will never taste good for
me you know a salad will never taste
good for me but but your body will learn
to find it utterly delicious and to
crave it in fact and the same will be
true for sex the same will be true for
entertainment um but it will be a
process
it's amazing um
how close the relationship is in all
things between delayed gratification and
wisdom
in other words a child will gravitate to
that thing that they want right now and
that the adult recognizes that actually
foregoing the thing you want right now
and investing in something deeper
sometimes even over the course of years
or longer is the way to ultimately end
up more satisfied but you know it's not
intuitive for a child and so in some
sense we are behaving in an increasingly
childlike fashion across
all of the human domains and it's an
error um thinking about the long term is
the way to go
okay brett and heather thank you very
much for coming on uh if anyone
listening isn't following you where can
they find you online
uh they can find us on the dark horse
podcast we do live streams every
saturday they can find us on twitter i
am at brett weinstein you are at heather
e hying
uh they can find our book
well do people buy books anywhere but
amazon
link below you can find it at the link
below and again that's a hunter
gatherer's guide to the 21st century yep
well congratulations guys thank you very
much for coming on nice meeting you
finally it's been successful
[Music]
you